il est près de 16 heures celui février
1900 quand 400 ouvriers agricoles arrive
devant l' usine sucrière du françois
avec la ferme intention de bloquer la
structure est de rallier ses salariés à
leur cause face à eux 25 soldats
dépéchés sur place en urgence fusil
armée ou bien quelqu'un qui s'est affolé
et a tiré le premier coaching ou bien
peut-être il y avait eu des heurts dans
ce sens et à partir sur mana bat pour
des coups de feu sont partis il ya une
trentaine de cartouches tirées et vous
avez u19 et 9 vous avez pour le 30 jeu
est blessé ce drame est le point d'orgue
de la grande grève de 1900 depuis 15 ans
la colère monte sur les habitations à
mesure que les conditions de travail se
dégradent situation due à la crise
mondiale du sucre évidemment il y à
baisser les prix de vente
les propriétaires les patrons et bien ce
disque qu'allons nous faire
on va agir sur la masse salariale
parallèlement la tâche augmente et des
conditions de vie sont rendus de plus en
plus difficile sur les habitations en
raison des pratiques qui ont cours comme
le caïd ont tous le piquant la paix
quand c'est une espèce de sanction
vous êtes prêté pour la vous
connaîtraient pas présents ou avoir fait
une mauvaise passe et n'avait créé ce
que nous appelons une crypto monnaie qui
était le bon t'as lika sy dos ça veut
dire que l'ouvrier ne pouvaient acheter
avec son salaire qu'à sur l'habitation à
la fin de la semaine je vais devoir
encore de l'argent parce que je savais
pas ce que je peux vous donner un ordre
d'idée un kilo de viande par exemple
coûter deux fois alors qu'un ouvrier le
côté ne paient pas du flan pour la
journée ne devait pas payer deux fois
c'est ainsi que débute la grande grève
autour de cette revendication principale
la mise en place d'un salaire minimum de
deux francs par jour
[Musique]
le mouvement prend naissance sur les
habitations de sainte marie et du
marigot avant de s'étendre plus au nord
au lorrain et à basse pointe et vers
trinité et le robert un peu plus au sud
les travailleurs partent de leur
habitation ils sont déjà sensibilisés
ils ont quelques meilleurs et ils vont
débaucher leurs camarades de travail sur
d'autres habitations afin de renforcer
le mouvement 400 ouvriers par ainsi de
plusieurs habitations du robert en
direction du françois
il emprunte la voie du chemin de fer qui
acheminent habituellement la canne à
sucre jusqu'à l'entrée nord de l' usine
là où des soldats les attendent
prêt à ouvrir le feu et ensuite ça
pétarade les notes les directions ou du
moins la direction des grévistes
officiellement la fusillade a fait 10
morts et 18 blessés dont 12 grièvement
atteints plusieurs ouvriers touchés
avaient regagné leurs cases et aurait
également succombé à leurs blessures
c'est la stupeur dans la commune
les gens peur parce que on est persuadé
qu'il ya des gens dans porto qui vont
assassiné tout le monde parce que ce
qu'on n'a pas dit c'est que ces gens
dorment là il était venu tellement pour
en découdre
c'était pas des gendarmes de réussite et
des militaires ce qu'ils avaient à
baïonnette au canon
c'est un fait de guerre etc au bâtiment
le bourg se trouvait en état de siège
il est également occupée jusqu'au mois
de mars à la mi mars par des troupes de
l'autre côté
par contre le mouvement s'étend encore
plus folle du côté de rivière saleen du
cos du saint-esprit à passant par le
lamantin la grande grève bénéficie
désormais du soutien des employés des
usines
c'est dans ce contexte que s'ouvrent les
négociations de rivière salée sur
l'habitation la guillot en présence du
grand propriétaire jean ayotte est
d'environ 2000 grévistes l'accord signé
le 15 février prévoit une augmentation
de salaire de 50 % ainsi que la
suppression du caïd oms et du piquant
c'est la première victoire ouvrière en
martinique acquise au prix du sang et en
os et aux anneaux sont des gens qui ont
eu le courage de s'opposer à ce qui
était une injustice notoire
cent vingt ans après certains continuent
de se battre pour que les noms des
victimes de février 1900 reste gravée à
jamais dans notre mémoire collective
à
[Musique]